Widespread publicly funded, mandatory education
has only been around since about the 19th
century.
Before then, the responsibility of providing
schooling to children fell primarily on their
families.
Upper- and middle-class families tended to
hire tutors or send their children to a private
school run by a schoolmaster.
That didn’t mean the children in lower-class
families missed out on learning how to read
and write.
They often learned this at home, through apprenticeships,
or at church-funded schools.
In addition, some poor families scraped together
enough money to pay for their children to
receive an education.
Some even worked out a barter arrangement
with teachers where they paid with surplus
produce from the family farm.
For instance, poor students from farming families
in Denmark and Sweden often brought baskets
of potatoes or apples to school as payment,
among other staples (the potato being used
for food, and the apple generally used for
making drinks at the time).
In the United States, things changed when
various social reforms came about in the 1800s.
The reforms addressed issues ranging from
food sanitation, treatment of the mentally
ill, and even education.
Schools became publicly funded and subject
to regulations in order to ensure that all
students were more or less getting the same
educational opportunity.
By 1913, a majority of the states in the United
States of America required that schools be
paid for by the government.
However towns on the sparsely settled western
frontier still often bore the responsibility
for paying for a teacher in the town.
As before, they recruited teachers, and they
provided a schoolhouse where classes could
be held, a place for the teachers to live,
fuel for heating, and often food.
In these sorts of arrangements, students were
also often tasked with helping the teacher
maintain the schoolhouse, such as gathering
on Saturdays to give it a thorough cleaning.
That tradition of bringing food to teachers
continued even as the United States government
took over the responsibility for funding public
education in the West.
The baskets of food were eventually replaced
with smaller amounts as the old “Boarding
Round” room and board pay system was replaced
by more in the way of a cash salary.
But why do schoolchildren traditionally give
apples to their teachers?
As mentioned, there are records of students
from such places as Denmark and Sweden bringing
both apples and potatoes to their teachers,
among other things, so why don’t students
traditionally give potatoes to teachers?
There are two generally accepted answers,
one or both of which possibly contributing
to this tradition over other food items like
the potato.
For the first theory, teachers were often
seen as a moral influence into the lives of
children.
(Indeed, the “Boarding Round” system often
insured that teachers toed the line with the
community’s moral standards- teach something
outside of this, and suddenly see something
like your food or heating fuel payment disappear.)
Along with this, the “Tree of Knowledge”
in the story of Adam and Eve in the Book of
Genesis has often been mistakenly referred
to as an apple tree.
This is partially thanks to Aquila Ponticus,
who was a second century translator translating
the Old Testament from Hebrew to Greek.
He took the liberty of referring to the Tree
of Knowledge as an apple tree, even though
the original text doesn’t say that.
It’s likely that he chose this due to the
fact that he was translating it into Greek
for Greeks and that in Greek mythology apples
were seen as symbols of desire and destruction.
Due to the prevalence of this “Tree of Knowledge”
/ apple tree idea, it wouldn’t be an out
of place gift, then, for students to give
their teachers an apple, the fruit representative
of knowledge.
On to the second popular theory for the continuance
of giving apples- apples arrived in North
America shortly after the Jamestown Colony
was founded in the early 1600s.
These apples, unlike the ones found in supermarkets
today, tasted bitter, but they could be used
to make hard apple cider.
Many people, whether rightly or wrongly, considered
hard cider a safer beverage than water because
widespread sanitation of drinking water did
not yet exist.
Apple trees also flourished in a variety of
climates, contributing to the popularity of
the fruit.
The sweeping social reforms that allowed schools
and education to become regulated also posed
a major problem for apples.
The temperance movement that spanned from
the mid-19th century to the early 20th century
sought to eliminate the drinking of alcohol
in the United States.
Apple growers scrambled to re-brand the fruit
in order to remove themselves from the controversy.
Careful cultivation caused the fruit to lose
its bitter taste and to become sweeter and
sweeter with each new generation of apples.
Marketing campaigns also played a part in
the apple’s new image.
Phrases like “An apple a day keeps the doctor
away” were dusted off and used to brand
the apple as a healthy snack.
So the theory goes that students and their
parents who wanted to get on a teacher’s
good side saw apples as a way to give the
teacher a healthy, cheap snack, which was
also quite versatile, able to be used now
for both drink and a sweet treat.
Thus, they chose to keep giving this food
item, rather than something like the potato.
The term “apple-polish” was coined in
the early 1900s and means that a student is
trying to get favors from their teacher- essentially
a brown-noser or suck-up.